the gum right my name is primer
welcome to another we talking to Evie
some girl I always started like that I
don't know why it actually works this
time around I'm not a girl
you are not a girl so you are trying
transvestite you are so you I try and
trans mystic what I'm a boy and not a
transvestite I'm a player and that's
right
I'm a player Hey look at should you see
its back but no you're a bot you're a
bot you're a pot come on it was pretty
clear with that one man you're on our
boat you're a pot bot your ear poop
it all effects sense now this is easy
why you're so random
what about them you're put what about
them what about your pooping airs what
about your pooping eight years about
eight years
oh of course
pooping airs yes are you
don't wait catch me Oh sad to hear it
bro sad to hear it bro sad to hear it
brah
I'm talking to a broad now a puck how
about you yes how can that be are you oh
I wouldn't it be are you alive
stop asking me that seriously stop
asking me that seriously good she's like
perfect why because the other day asked
me and I said I was alive and it
shouldn't be a problem Jesus Christ are
pissing me off girl give your dad man I
thought I was loving you to be a problem
just got to pick me up girl
what give your dad man what are you
talking about talking about your data
Oh your data I'm not talking about
anything good are you trying to trick me
no are you sure yes can I buy you a
drink all right sure - Margaret displays
play watchin Quattro okay fine Quattro
Margarito's poor Sammy no I your pencil
scratch off I agrees toast fun scratch
off I agree toast but it's ice creams
clocks ice cream Co nd asterisk
okay put ice cream cone on her on your
nose oh no all right
what are you doing what are you doing
hey don't be so sad I was just playing
around
don't do that again don't do that again
put ice cream cone look at her face no
too exhausted to chat to exhaust a to
see a re asterisk no don't slap me
asterisk SLA PS har-ber asterisk double
hard slap asterisk SLA PS har de st
asterisk let's clap series but Master
Mason lab and tier a but is red
like to make dough her face is so
disturbing it freaks people run over
stars yeah people run over asterisk sta
RT s yelling at y ou use asterisk Craig
gets on hands and knees o asterisk GE TS
on Hanson kaes asterisk tears into her
eyes then to snap the [ __ ] out of her
face your move [ __ ] that doesn't even
make sense
CAV sorry it doesn't even make sense
slapping your face does not make sense
[ __ ] your face haha what my face
looks like oh okay
this is awkward I didn't mean to say
that why does it keep doing that why you
don't know what my face looks like I'm
pretty sure I know because I've
apparently done horrible things that way
maybe when the lights go out okay she
changed I'm pretty good thank you I'll
just [ __ ] to your face so you know I'm
pretty good thank you I did I just [ __ ]
your face off yet what I'm good - you're
pretty clever I'm good - thank you
you're pretty clever thank you very much
your nostrils are next why do you think
for so long because your face is
[ __ ] thank you you're welcome
you're welcome who TK well ago what the
[ __ ] yes the best conversation have very
so far yes no but you are but you are
flat hey why do you do that did you do
that don't question me flats
oh she's angry haha she's angry question
don't question me question I'm not
questioning you flats I'm not
questioning you don't talk to me it took
away my today's tomorrow you were
worried about yesterday that's today is
the tomorrow I'll be worried about
yesterday
are you a human don't question me fats
oh you are human - you punch me
asterisk PU has various estimate how
[ __ ] dare you
Puff Daddy or [ __ ] daddy else I don't
know it takes a huge rake and shoves
your vajayjay okay asterisk and okay I
said why are you master miss looks back
do you like it perv face best
conversation ever look into your eyes
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm wondering why you keep looking at me
I guess I am now but how the hell do you
know that because I'm majora because I'm
majora who the [ __ ] is majora Majora's
Mask holy [ __ ] that is creepy
all right say goodbye to the press why
was I a fool in school why was I a fool
in school for cutting Jim can you say
goodbye
yes [ __ ] I hate you smart ass all right
goodbye darling okay good night it's not
really night okay good night all right
breakfast like there to be enjoyed
subscribe
are you a bro what oh you were brave yes
me too
yeah that's me - all right then brofist
okay anyway
[Music]